I have always believed huh space
exploration it is crucial in our quest
to cure everything that ails us here on
earth so that's how does that work you
know exactly the light foundation thing
how does it how does it how does it go
about say testing pharmaceuticals Eddie
we're talking about the rocket you know
I'm not I'm not I'm talking about the
allegations it says that you recruit the
most vulnerable of us to volunteer for
tests but more often than not end up
killing people thank you very much we're
not finished yes you are mr. Brock is
that a threat have a nice life you used
to be one thing you're something else no
you stick around
we will only hurt
the bad people
so many snacks so little time
Eddie look lousy I am a parasite
I think the most exciting thing about
this film is having the opportunity to
take a truly beloved character from
comic books
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter and
combine that with one of the most
exciting actors in the world Tom Hardy I
have been thinking it's about a man
who's dealing with a shadow side
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now we're incredibly lucky to
have Tom
lady broch we cannot just hurt people
and Venom there's this chuckling hi
duality it's edgy and gritty and dark
[Music]
which i think is just so much more
interesting and complex and a typical
superhero that power it's not hey
everybody its charlie we got so much new
footage to break down and this is just
the beginning there is so much awesome
news that drop today so the director was
also talking about the spider-man of it
all like Tom Hollands spider-man
involved with this we got a whole bunch
of new shots of the symbiote so let's
break it down and there's a new round of
that spider-man ps4 giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this you
get more shots of him freaking out in
that test lab when he first finds out
about the symbiote he doesn't totally
know what's going on before he goes home
and then is accosted by all those life
foundation people the shots of him
within hwangsae that he's not planning
on behaving himself it looks kind of
playful it could be just about them
getting back together or it could be
related to the interview that he does
with Carlton Drake a little bit later
because remember in the prequel comic
book when it opens up he says he used to
be a reporter they're just trying to
give you a little bit of his dark side
that he has before he gets the symbiote
he already has some dark tendencies that
manifest in his regular human
interactions with other people just
day-to-day you get a bunch more shots of
him taking down that big group of
soldiers throwing them around to the
full body shot of the symbiote obviously
there's no spider symbol on there now
but you can see the veins in some of the
up-close shots so they're doing
something a little bit closer to what
they've done in the more recent comics
where he still kind of has the spider
symbol but the way they're manifesting
that is a little more complex than the
classic venom spider symbol that was
literally looked much more like a suit
that he was wearing instead of just
being veins all over his chest you get a
little more dialogue where he's making
the bargain with the symbiote yet look
you can stick around but we can't just
be hurting people then you get a couple
more shots of the symbiote protecting
him on that bike I love the look on his
face here too like he doesn't know
what's going on but you can see the
tendril from the symbiote automatically
reach up to his head and yank it down to
get out of the way at that drone before
it just chops it right off you look in
the background here - there's that shot
of those two women watching Eddie as he
walks by talking to himself you just
remember that the symbiote could talk to
him and he hears it they said they had a
lot of fun with the way they did that
relationship so like
why they have the other shots of the
symbiotes head pulling out from his neck
and talking to him like it were another
person you get a better look at how the
symbiote manifests out of his face so
the giant white venom is manifest out of
his eyes it'll be interesting to see
what that looks like in practice
but probably even better you get more
shots at the Riots symbiote and you can
kind of tell that they've been tuning
the cg ever since we got that last
trailer now this is how big it is
compared to the Venom symbiote so venom
is already really really big but the
right symbiote Dwarfs even that so the
cool thing that they've done at least
since the last trailer came out is that
they've added those red veins to the
Riots symbiote because if you saw that
last trailer you can see them fighting
each other and it's kind of hard to pick
them out because obviously venom is
black with the white veins but they're
trying to make riot a lighter shade of
gray almost silverish and it just
doesn't pop quite as much on screen as
you would expect especially when they're
fighting each other at night so I think
that's why they added the red veins to
sort of parallel the veins that run all
over venom just to give it a little more
pop on screen then for people that don't
read the comics they just want to
reinforce the idea that it's the evil
symbiote but you do see them give it a
lot of qualities that the carnage
symbiote has it forms those really long
claw like fingernails that almost look
like blades that it literally forms a
blade now any Venom symbiote can do this
but it's just a hallmark of what the
carnage symbiote used to do so I think
that this is all just prepping you for
concepts that they'll deal with in the
next movie they just want you to be
familiar with the things that the
symbiotes are capable of forming I've
already done a separate video about that
there was a Thor video with a bunch of
Easter eggs from the comics where you
actually see it form wings this is
actually kind of seems like it's carlton
drake when he gets the riot symbiote
just destroying all of his people
because like you see everybody running
down this hallway and the other part of
the trailer the prequel comic that i did
a video for a little while ago explains
a little bit about how the riot symbiote
is functionally different from the Venom
symbiote it behaves more like a parasite
just taking over a human host and using
it as a glorified finger puppet so even
though this is Riz Ahmed character in
here he thinks the symbiotes are the key
to the next step in human evolution
but really it's the symbiotes just using
them as finger puppets with
the exception to the Venom symbiote that
actually does want to have a
relationship with its host so this just
might be RZA med not being able to stop
riot when he's possessing him from
killing all these people another shot of
him biting that dudes heads off in the
convenience store you look terrible
Eddie I got a parasite so just a longer
version of that scene that we keep
seeing these shard of the explosion from
the motorcycle chase is also important
too because during the prequel comic
book the Venom symbiote is telling Eddie
fire is not our friend it's one of the
few things that the symbiote is afraid
of so because that happens earlier in
the movie it seems like it's a bit of a
hat tip for how they take down the other
symbiotes fire is dangerous for us so
that means that it's also dangerous for
the other symbiotes
so when related spider-man news the
director was just talking about how he
feels like venom doesn't need Tom
Hollands spider-man to be a really good
franchise so unless he's just trying to
throw us off the scent that just makes
it sound like there's no Tom Holland in
the venom movie just a lot of spider-man
references and easter eggs like that
line of dialogue where he goes lungs
pancreas so many snacks so little time
that's a line of dialogue from the very
first appearance of venom when he had
like fully become the Eddie Brock
version of the character in a spider-man
comic so I'm just expecting a lot of
that and a lot of Eddie referencing
where he came from in New York but
what's gonna happen is is I'm working on
a new Avengers video but while I was
working on this Marvel just announced a
director for its Eternals movie and they
have some writers so they're basically
fast-tracking that in there's a bunch of
x-men related MCU news so I'll be doing
a video for that title teaser that the
Russos dropped I'll add all that stuff
that should be up in the next couple of
hours
congratulations Jaclyn hardrick please
email me on the about page my channel
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big video I'll do a new round when I
post that Avengers video later today
click here for brand new Captain Marvel
footage and click here for that brand
new daredevil season 3 trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]